pop
[Musique]
m
ap vétérinaire
[Musique]
lyon avril 1965 des émissions de radio
de télévision des bandes d'actualités ou
des articles de journaux consacrés à la
délinquance
vous en avez vu entendu et lu beaucoup
mais d'habitude ce que l'on s'attache à
montrer ce sont les délinquants dans ce
qu'ils ont de spectaculaire un peu comme
des vedettes et aussi ce qui est fait
pour comme on dit les rééduquer et
aujourd'hui ce que nous allons faire
c'est les regarder vivre ces délinquants
là où il vit le ton cas c'est un des
quartiers de lyon qui est la plus
mauvaise réputation
dans certaines familles on est
délinquant de père en fils mais ça ne
choque absolument personne et quand on
est délinquant là c'est au milieu de
l'indifférence générale jeta phénomène à
qui personne ne s'en occupe
et les adultes qui sont là ni même la
patronne de ce café
qui trouve que tous les garçons qui sont
là sont bons jeunes gens bien convenable
qui ne veut pas savoir ce qui se passe
par ailleurs
[Musique]
c'est déjà du quartier dans les centres
est lente et namur est tous un peu
turbulent dix ans
on tombait bien
non non non non le modèle si vous avez
aimé soumet jeunes est-ce que vous ayez
on en a une on n'y va pas pourquoi vous
n'allez pas la maison des jeunes
attaquent la trompette
alors on y va plus on y allait mondiale
va les gens qui s'en occupent les aimait
pas
non mais je pense à la terrasse vous
aimez mieux rester entre vous ne seriez
pas entre vous à la maison des jeunes
non mais c'est pas pareil au même
et l'argent ça vous intéresse erreur je
voudrais y en avoir beaucoup
est ce que vous feriez pour en avoir
beaucoup la cour n'a pas quoi mais
materis
qu'est-ce qui vous montre
des libertés meilleur que libertine sont
pas assis bras non non ils sont coincés
grand jeu
je pense moi je te prends vraiment vous
répondent comme enfin sans peau assez
grand les garçons qui tourne mal
est ce que vous croyez qu'ils sont
beaucoup d' excuse moi il y en a
beaucoup
madame mais ce qu'a fait toni ce que les
garçons du couac est ce que vous pensez
de j'ai trop formidable ça vous paraît
normal qu'ils se réunissent dans une
maison ailleurs va naturellement ce qui
manque dans ton casque une maison de
jeunes qui n'y vont pas alors là je ne
sais pas alors je suis pas au courant
j'avais un petit garçon ralentir avec
nico je ne crois pas je crois qu'ils ont
l'intention d'y passer six ans pour
pour cette année ça vous fait la peine
parce que c'est un gardien
oui oui je l'aimé énormément le reste il
ya très peu de temps que je suis dame je
me suis très vite habilité matijevic est
réalisé avec toi je suis très content
qu'il a écrasé à la croix rousse nous
avons rencontré une famille française
qui à 17 ans marie-hélène sa soeur et
leurs parents pour la mère de francis et
de marie-hélène n'y a aucun problème
elle aime ses enfants elle ne les voit
pas tout à fait comme ils sont vous avez
combien d'enfants piano quatre mains qui
ont quel âge saison c'est un an et demi
19 20 14 ans et 12 ans et demi et vous
vous ne travaillez par une travailleuse
dit madame et que ce qu'ils font vos
enfants
genia qui est apprenti dans notre cité
le second est dans les amas journée du
rallye promenade ils ont fait celui qui
dans l'électricité afin de quantis âge
eloïne après les rencontres à venir au
mois deux mois de juin ah oui et ça lui
qui dans sa page où
db les 50 talibans m alors qu'est ce
qu'elle est belle mais alors pas retenu
membre vous pouvez me dire combien
gagnent tous les deux doivent gagner 34
mine mais un salaire quoi c'est ça oui
christian gagne 14 34 milles et francis
aussi ribéry et comment ça se passe avec
leur salaire et vous lui donnez vous
leur donner un petit peu d'argent je
leur donne vers ce moment dans le corps
par n'a rien de base des fondements d'un
puits à l'heure il me donne mais je leur
donne vous comprenez combien vous leur
donnez à peu près pour leur distraction
je sais pas si 1000 par mois sur 7
milliards - oui et quand ils ont besoin
de graver en six mois qu'ils habillent
est ce que c'est vous qui choisissez ou
est ce que c'est que je vais avec un
oeil sont difficiles comment vous vous
entendez avec vos enfants bien bien bien
bien bien gentil ya jamais de problème
jamais de petit nombre avec les filles
veulent pas que les garçons sont très
gentils pourquoi il ya plus de problème
est réglé parce qu'elles sont fondées
chinoise il ya maintenant quoi ça me
sont pas gentils façon façon d'un label
cours at t et les qu'open office qu'est
ce que vous en pensez ce que vous voulez
mais c'est à dire que je connais pas
beaucoup je compte j'en connais
michel we surveiller beaucoup au pas
tellement non j'ai pas le temps je n'ai
pas le temps d'y surveiller
j'ai confiance je que je leur fais
confiance je leur fais confiance entre
gentils et sur quoi vous basez pour leur
faire confiance simplement sur le fait
qu'ils sont gentils wissant correct vous
vous dites que vous les avez bien aimé
oui d'accord oui à quelle heure ils
rendent par exemple le sel alors ça
dimanche minuit je n'ai pas en quoi je
me sens très en retard ne vous inquiétez
bien me fait beaucoup de mauvais singe
que je ne dors pas voulait disputer
alors s'ils rentraient de leur demain je
triais minuit vous dis je leur fais
confiance parce qu'ils sont bien élevés
qu est ce qui vous paraît important
qu'on vienne et leurs bêtes parce que je
peux pas te faire du mal
vous comprenez voilà alors le plus
important pour moi est ce que c'est de
les dresser comme on dit ou est ce que
c'est de les aimer de tous les ennemis
des courriers sentiment très fort
mécontentement le zenbook commencer puis
est ce qu'ils voudront a dit ce que vous
croyez qu'il y ait une confiance réelle
en crever ben je ne sais pas ce qu un
chef qui peuvent quoi ça vous ennuie un
keeper je voudrais qu'il soit plus ils
me disent bien leurs affaires comme le
disent à christian gross coach voudrait
qu'il me dise un peu fils et leur père
vous comprenez
pour ce faire il est normal qu'un garçon
de 19 ans est claire je peux de la même
langue le croyez moi je vois pas comme
ça je les aime pour moi qu'est ce que
vous pensez des jeunes gens qui tournent
mal mais je reviens petit peu des
parents moi je prends à bouilly parce
que moi quand je vois que les miens ça
va pas alors là je fais attention
moi je leur dis fuck qu'il y avait
peut-être copains il faut qu'il fasse
bien tensions les mauvaise fréquentation
c'est quand je me donne pas je n'en ai
pas
quatremer viennent me dire qu'elle
regrettait que n'ayez pas tout à fait
assez confiance en elle est ce que ça
vous paraît possible de raconter tout ce
qui vous arrive dans la ville
[Musique]
oui ou non au oui même en temps de fêtes
qu'est ce que vous lui raconter pas ce
que vous faites avec mes copains quand
vous sortez en banque au bord s'allume
ford a perdu raconte pas lorsqu'on lui
raconte on lui dit ouais ce qui est pas
méchant co et pendant tout ce qui est
méchant bon lui dit pro et qu'est-ce qui
peut être mais champagne comme des
nîmois développé chez palm os déconner
on appelle à icônes et hop s'amuser
entre copains co
se balader antonio
ouais des voitures elle m'a dit aussi
qu'elle n'avait plus d'ennuis avec ses
filles qu'avec ses fils la paille en
décoller très bon air sévère
pourquoi ça marche pas mieux
parce que quand je vais à l'école
un défi qui m'entraînent alors je les
supplie j'arrive tard à la maison alors
à eux disputent le dispute moi un petit
peu ordinaire
vous avez l'air de moins bien subir
l'autorité de votre mère qu aux frères
je pense
qu'est ce que vous feriez si vous êtes
libre de faire uniquement ce que vous
voulez c'est votre mère était pas là
pour empêcher que jamais à la maison
vous seriez dehors avec j'écoute ça
beaucoup d'importance pour vous les
copains ou les garçons et filles
dans les deux qu'est ce que vous
préférez les films et les garçons les
cartons
voire franchement s'amuse mieux vous
amuser bien perso si vous rencontriez un
garçon que ce garçon soit fasse partie
d'une bande et que vous ayez
l'impression qu'il va faire des bêtises
qui pourrait le mener loin et lui gâcher
un peu la vie vous essayez d'en empêcher
jal dépend
quand plusieurs qui disent oui on peut
rien fait on peut rien faire on peut que
subir
oui
et vous est-ce que ça vous gênerait si
vous rencontriez un garçon qui ait eu
des ennuis qu'ils étaient en prison
est ce que ça changerait votre
comportement à son égard ce que vous
l'aimeriez moi est ce que vous le verrez
un an pour vous finalement c'est un
petit peu normal qu'on ait des ennuis
quand on est en âge vous paraissait bien
plus révolté que les autres la pression
vous n'êtes pas vraiment contente vous
d'avis que vous venez de ce que vous
faites quand celle ci mais j'aime pas
l'école n'aimais pas l'école et fière de
vous aimer alors vous promener chaque
acteur et vous aimeriez avoir beaucoup
d'argent large
non je trais suivant m'amuser quoi le
cinéma avec ma copine
le garçon
et ça vous pouvez parler en ont
et le jour où vous le pourrez onfray en
vue d'accords est ce que vous seriez
prête à vous fâchez très très fort avec
votre mère pour pouvoir le faire
oui
parce que vous partiriez de chez vous il
veut
ça dépend
qu'il le fallait oui et vous pensez sans
les regarder d'argent pour sortir
non on n'est jamais assez la
en bon on ne réclame douze teintes us et
pour tout le temps qu'elle vous en
donner pour ma part un petit peu plus
on y en ait un peu plus si je veux
j'insiste versys elle donne quoi
[Musique]
on va
tant mieux
moi je
francis christian sam michel voudrait
bien entrer dans une boîte de nuit
ils ne peuvent pas encore un échec
[Musique]
finalement ces échecs c'est ce qui fait
toute leur vie et c'est peut-être leur
plus grosse difficulté selon les
éducateurs pour les aider vraiment ils
font leur donner des occasions de
triompher mais c'est peut-être le plus
difficile y aller autant s'ils veulent
aller autant ces questions se fait
chasser
voilà deux cours ont mené en allemagne
ces trotteurs savais pas mais des bruits
mais comment vous faites un garçon là il
y en a pas été capable de sortir avec
une fille en est capable mais j'ai
décidé c'est autre chose
elles sont toutes pareilles les filles
je crois que s'il ya ma vie avec vous
c'est parce que vous avez peur d'elle
cette timide
dans sa question à la casquette n'ont vu
nos tenues quand même problème
maintenant les faits elles sont beaucoup
plus sérieuse car
et j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
ces bruits pour la tenue et puis
peut-être qu'ils sont plus calés en ces
mots et vous les étudiants
un faux pas en parler je les aime pas je
prenais vraiment fait mon cours michael
booth et guizmo binaire ben on peut pour
bien dire beaucoup parce que tu poses
l'habillement c'est surtout ça surtout
l'habillement et puis ils en parlent et
ils ont un peu parlé d' anciens et des
gens assez respectable un jeune c'est
respectable accord mais j'y pense je le
sais mais gueuler voilà c'est surtout ça
[Musique]
ça rigole peut-être mais pendant les
mêmes principes
il ya peut-être deux ou trois qui sont
sympathiques mais par contre les autres
ouais c'est plutôt ça n'allait pas
l'impression mois jaloux [ __ ] le
projet après giallo l'info va beaucoup
plus est ce que vous croyez qu'ils ont
fait
bon bah nos bons ils ont peut-être les
moyens c'est tout bon on s'amuse on
discute en force en lui pour quoi bon
s'amuse à faire les petites conneries
s'amuse en mobylette roule quoi bon ben
on pense pas aux autres
bon ça arrive jamais nous
voici ce qu'en pense le principal
intéressé
le commissaire divisionnaire schaffner
les délits commis par les jeunes
délinquants sont très nombreux c'est à
dire que on retrouve évidemment dans la
criminalité juvénile
on retrouve à peu près toutes les formes
de délinquance des adultes c'est à dire
que non ça va si vous voulez du crime
jusqu'au délits moins graves du crime
par conséquent de l'homicide du côté les
moins graves qui sont ciblés le vol sein
alors dans cette danse est dans ses
limites et donner vanté lors
d'infractions qu'on retrouve je crois
qu'il ya quand même deux actuellement
c'est c'est à mon avis ça aussi enfin
ces percées assez typique assez
symptomatique
je crois qu'on trouve essentiellement
parfum de la formation lyonnaise deux
formes on retrouve deux formes plus
fréquemment ce pas par exemple tout ce
qui touche à la sexualité
et puis elle aurait tous ceux qui tout
ce qui est vol alors tout ce qui vole
multiples n'est ce pas je crois que
c'est là que se situe essentiellement la
délinquance juvénile effet commissaire
quant à la suite d'un délit un
adolescent temps entre les mains de la
police
est ce parce qu'elle processus normal
c'est à dire que le mineur arrêter le
mieux rater et entendu bien et bien
entendu est entendue et ensuite alors
s'il est vraiment coupable
il parle et déféré au parquet ceux ci il
n'y a pas de difficultés du tout pas de
ce que j'aimerais vous m'expliquez sait
où il va parce que nous avons constaté
que ça ça les inquiétait beaucoup au
moment où ils s'entassent oui alors on
ne soit arrêté à lyon au niveau des
peaux à tendance à louis elle remet à
son parc à lyon
ils viennent d'abord ici en principe rue
faux pas et vous c'est que l'arrivée
pensée personnes bol pour les mineurs
délinquants notamment
est-ce que toujours on traite les
enfants comme ils veulent être précis
c'est à dire on y trouve toujours madame
alors là c'est absolument formel on les
traite comme des enfants comme des
adolescents comme des mineurs
délinquants mineurs mais pas comme des
adultes jamais commis les enfants vont
tout de même en prison au quartier des
mineurs de la prison symbole
on manque de place
nous allons aller maintenant dans un
centre d'observation de délinquants des
jeunes y sont en semi liberté et c'est
la forme de justice la moins répressive
en france il travaille dans la journée
le soir ils rentrent et à l'issue de ce
stage la justice décide si elle les
garde sous sa tutelle ou si elle les
rend à leurs parents mais maman d un
petit peu ce qui s'est passé personne ne
dit pas son nom
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous voyez un peu tout
tout ce que j'avais envie d'acheter pour
simplement qu'ils pouvaient acheter
j'avais de l'argent pour le chantre et
sait quel genre de trucs
non seulement ce que je voulais pour le
maroc ou à disques à limerick n ai peur
qu est ce qui vous est arrivé un jour où
cette fois ci c'est pour le jour 2 2 on
est là à partir du moment où on est
prêts qu est ce qui se fait répond
l'homme à paris
qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé à partir
du moment où vous avez décrit on a été
interrogé notre jeu
mais pendant qu'est ce que c'est cela
brouille a trop cherché plus fatales sur
les genoux
oui c'était la listeria thouars c'est un
type de violence
le voleur et vous j'ai rien vous avez la
même expérience que j'appelle bunge
entre le soir du travail puis je pouvais
passer chez moi il y avait du bruit je
prépare à sortir
pourquoi ben on assez nombreux chez moi
alors très bien
7 cet enfant de la favec des parents est
pas très grand et je sens de voir quoi
il y avait un groupe de jeunes il y en
avait quelques uns je connaissais déjà
enfin le plus rapproché je veux faire
des cigarettes et on a parlé de un
certain enfin je dirai pas le nom et on
discute avec lui j'ai vu que lui aussi
faisait des idioties coiffe sortait
comme ça faisait des vols je me suis
d'accord avec lui et on est sortis
ensemble et lui c'est un majeur il avait
déjà il a déjà fait des reprises en
trois fois je crois
ensuite j'avais décidé depuis sortir
avec lui et le troisième soir où je
sortais plus pour plus le rencontrer
pendant ces soirs là il s'est pas trompé
par les produits par la police et il m'a
dénoncé à vauban je lis que ces départs
auraient pas j'ai nié et il est venu
voir moi il a dit devant les policiers
tout ce qu'on avait fait quoi alors là
j'ai dit mais il est fou ce gars ça va
pas pendant que vous étiez l'un et
l'autre
petit dépôt et l'autre à symbole est ce
que vous avez réfléchi nu mais est ce
que vous êtes et fériés de faire prendre
ou d'avoir fait pas du tout j'étais
passé rural solo ce qui m'ennuie c'est
pour ma famille quoi sinon pour moi sont
entrés dans la ville où est ce que vous
avez trouvé une différence réelle entre
le comportement d'un juge pour les
adultes et la juge peut rien faire je ne
sais pas encore parce que joe qu'une
nouvelle juste enfants mon seul juge de
lui et il était mieux préjuge pour les
adultes ou manière appareils sont
nombreux leur part est injuste c'est
toujours un jeune chaîne voyage toujours
le veut on nous a dit qu'il y avait
beaucoup de viol c'est comme l'était
dans le devon et ses liens c'était parce
que les garçons à 20h02 d'arriver comme
ils ont peur d'être à leur fille qui se
comptent pour aller les vagues ça finit
toujours très rare d'y penser ça non je
trouve ça ridicule et vous non pas se
dire qu'il a fait c'est vraiment avec
également que saleh ce qu elle est
consentante
autrement ça veut pas et réussit à fond
de ruelles de pouce quoi animer
plusieurs c'est à dire plusieurs petites
assiettes forme ça va laisser quelques
130 me retrouve donc le vieux ne savons
pas un pareil non
ça dépend des cas en effet vous trouvez
que c'est agréable
enfin c'est pas là pour l'instant pour
avoir raison que la fille que j'aime ne
m'aime pas j'avais une fille j'étais
avec elle elle a su que j'ai fait ça
alors ce procès est entré dans
l'administration
enfin un métier où on est une retraite
plus tard ce que tu travailles toute sa
vie comme ça pour coréen
quand on est vieux pasqua vous n'avez
pas 18 ans il vous pensez déjà à l'arrêt
je joue bien mais entre le moment où
vous avez 18 ans maintenant contraire
[Musique]
michel le nihiliste est un des seuls
lycéens du centre arrêté pour port et
fabrication d'armes à feu michel rêvait
de rétablir sur son trône à souverains
étrangers
mais d'une vision n'était surtout pas
justement sortir surtout est ce que vous
pensez des juges
ça je ne suis pas le seul à le dire mais
les juges femmes de man sont évidemment
plus sévères que les hommes
une façon géniale c'est ce qu'on m'a dit
ce que j'ai pu vérifier mon ami vous
avez affaire un juge à et entre vous il
ya eu 40 altran pensions non beaucoup de
sévérité de sa part
si vous avez une passion qu'elle n'a pas
cadré
non seulement parce que la joute
personne ne m'a jugé exactement sous
même blanc chez votre feuille comme le
juge pas à quoi vous croyez
l'expérience m'a appris qu'il fallait
pas avoir grand chose
oui mais tout ce que vous avez fait vous
le démontre que vous croisiez quelque
chose vous avez des activités politiques
chantôme est emmené dans un sens très
précis oui ils ont pouvait elle pas
jaloux d'extrême gauche
non ce serait plutôt le contraire non
c'est pas ambitions je suis douloureux
vous êtes de droite par ambitions
commencent à la situation risque de
devenir plus importante par la droite et
cette situation vous la voyez comment la
future qu'est ce que vous souhaitez
faire
pour faire le plein ce que les garçons
du centre certes vous avez peut-être
vous êtes à révolter
on va révolutionner bon nom que j'ai
l'esprit de compétition et j'ai mauvais
des fossés la rancune je ne nourris pas
tout le temps comme ça
d'armagh et contre entre tous les gens
qui en fait vous soyez là maintenant non
seulement en général entre des gens qui
m'ennuyait si méchant que vous avez
effectué ici qu'est ce que ça vous a
remarqué mais non parce que ça me fera
changer cela vous aurez appris quelque
chose
on suspend sport tous sauf à détester
quelques gens supplémentaire et ça ne
sera peut-être pas donner un tout petit
peu de tendresse pour les gens que
j'aime en pole
oh
[Musique]
la guitare et la chanson tiennent une
grande place dans la vie des garçons la
plupart préfèrent le rock mais julien
lui est un sentimental
tu as
dans ce
ouais deux mois
au près de moi
[Musique]